you don't like saying I can fall in love
no he's married to his job huh he's the
person who gives us all of the gifts but
if you're bad he gives you a piece of
coal he's an old man about 40 mm I got
sick probably over 100 years old and I
don't I don't believe that I'm just
predicting nice not real there's no way
somebody can live for over a thousand
years he has a flying sled a flying
reindeer yeah so how did the reindeer
fly I'm good I had no clue because he's
magic and he's gonna make it oh baby
nurse five there's no way that flying
Randers is true parents make it up so
they can think it's me Oh then when you
really grow up your mom's just gonna
tell you sad it's not real I'm just
gonna remember that till you have kids
he knows everything he does not have
cameras he is magic he got some
assistance and those are the Oh stay and
I look what they are oh and you always
have a Christmas tree
if you don't where will send it put the
presents he delivers his presence but
does the Christmas tree and that's go to
different houses silly North Pole when
he has a gingerbread house yes he have
like a few neighbors like me being the
elves no that's a real place they made
you believe so far away you're never
gonna go there what I'm a teenager I'm
gonna go there I'm gonna look throughout
every place every place and your mom
you're coming with me
and you're gonna tell me where the North
Pole is he's going on vacation to get
relax
so we'll be writing down for next year
the beach I guess the North Beach he
goes to Hawaii California places that
you could just be all relaxed danced a
little work she never came jumper well I
think he can go to winter Wow and they
come easily
Santa whaling robe the handy-dandy
enjoying the elves before I draw a Santa
so like you know it takes time he is
going out outfit you know Santa does
have a what if actually cream is Bertha
actually Bertha was a one that is
usually just enough Easter Bunny she's
in charge of Easter these feet oh he
doesn't work you know since I have
enough money he gave it all the kids how
does he get down the jiminy breaking
your door bust alarm he'll go down your
chimney baby's reindeers go for a gimme
enough because he's magic no those are
called the fake Santa's you're just
stress up so they could get money let me
it's gonna ask me to draw hands I'm
getting to it I said Santa was a cow yes
because he's magic a sheep a little egg
seriously tactical real favor very rude
fault
alright fault and John eats everything
that is edible Aaron I'm done finish I
just can't wait to see this yes yes
you just stress up so they could get
money you know the roof